Our story
yes, what exactly is your story really I
mean I think it's a perfectly simple question
honestly why did you come here
Welcome back everyone congratulations you made it
the marvel drought is over we finally have brand
new marvel content after a year with no movies
this will be my Wandavision episode 1 video there
were a whole bunch of easter eggs so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes so be
sure to subscribe to get everything we're also
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite wtf moment on the video
but careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet i'm going to number these a little
bit differently just because there's so much
stuff happening in the first couple of episodes as
they're kind of realizing what's actually going on
in this alternate reality they didn't give
any special titles to the first couple of
episodes it's just episode 1 and episode 2 so i'm
assuming it's going to be similar for the rest of
the episodes but they start with a new version of
the marvel studios logo that incorporates all the
newer movie footage all the way through avengers
end game and some of the disney plus series that
are going on you also begin the episode the
opening scene in their fictional alternate
reality as if it's the intro to this 1950s looking
tv show obviously because it's the 1950s most of
their references are i love lucy and a little bit
of bewitched sometimes it's a little bit easier
to tell which specific shows they're parodying
based on some of the scenes but all the intro
songs starting with this one are different for the
different decades of different sitcoms so they're
all kind of made to feel like they would have
been theme songs for tv shows written in these
different decades but because this is disney they
have the hookup they got the people that wrote
the music for the frozen movies to do the theme
songs for the different episodes they're moving
into west view which is a reference to west coast
avengers there's also obviously a lot of visual
references of what's going on in the neighborhood
too but they're driving into the suburbs basically
to start their new life together because they're
supposed to be newlyweds their address on the
street here 2800 is also a reference to avengers
issue number 280 where jarvis came back to the
avengers after almost having died at the hands
of one of the villains in an earlier issue
vision just died during avengers infinity war and
was created from parts of jarvis the problem you
start to notice through the episode though is that
there's all these inconsistencies and they even
reference writing their story as they go along
because scarlet witch is literally writing their
story as she goes along so they move into their
new house and she kind of magics it up like oh
it's sold it's ours now it belongs to us he tries
to do that traditional thing of carrying the bride
through the threshold but because he's vision
he phases through the door that's also another
callback to captain america civil war because
scarlet witch kept telling him not to do that
vision we talked about this you're not supposed
to do that she references their powers i can fly
you're super strong you're an android they make
a joke about him not eating food because he's an
android they actually referenced that a couple
times during the first couple of episodes and
her wanting to cook him this giant breakfast
how would you feel about that well i wouldn't
feel anything because i'm not going to eat it we
get that opening scene that they dropped a little
while ago i already did a video for this it's
all about the comedy of them not remembering what
their special date is the heart on the calendar
but we find out what was actually really going on
if you look at the date on the calendar too it's
august 23rd 2023 because this is all happening
after avengers end game even though it all looks
like it's happening in a 1950s television show
my assumption when we first saw this scene is that
it was actually just a reference to them having
sex for the first time which is what she thinks
for the first half of the episode so obviously
this is a big sitcom trope of the husband and wife
getting themselves into this hilarious situation
with the dinner party you notice the laugh track
a lot of the tropes of classic sitcoms of that
era or really sitcoms all the way up through the
90s there'll be a laugh track i'm sure in some of
the other subsequent episodes but they say that
they try to be as period-specific when they were
actually making these episodes so they used really
old-timey cameras black and white cameras of the
decade to film these particular black and white
episodes they had a live studio audience i'm sure
those people had to sign ndas and their firstborn
children away to marvel in order to get in that
audience you also notice a lot of easter eggs for
i love lucy she looks at the camera breaking the
fourth wall like lucille ball did during that tv
show it's also a clever way of referencing that
she's one of the few people that actually knows
that she's inside a fake reality she's inside
an actual tv show but it's not real deadpool
would be proud breaking that fourth wall
we meet catherine hahn's nosy neighbor character
who's calling herself agnes but i obviously i
think that's a fake name i think she's really
meant to be a version of agatha harkness from the
comics who's another sorceress just like doctor
strange who helps scarlet witch at various times
she's kind of been a mentor to scarlet witch
but you notice through a lot of the different
scenes it seems like she knows more than she's
letting on the references that she makes with
some of her dialogue so it also seems like she
knows that this reality isn't actually real
you start to notice some of the inconsistencies
though and scarlet witch kind of starts to flip
out a little bit only a little bit during this
episode but it starts to get worse and worse
and worse as reality around her starts to crack
just a little bit like things aren't quite right
she skirts the fact about not having a moving
company because she literally just moved in and
used her powers to make the house theirs and
create all this furniture she tries to cover
for the fact that there's no rings on her finger
she doesn't know what their anniversary date is or
how long they've been together it feels like we've
been together for forever it's all because she's
literally creating a lot of this on the fly as she
goes we find out that inside this reality vision
works at a company called computational services
which is obviously a reference to him being an
android but also sort of an old-timey version
of ibm they make a couple jokes about him not
knowing what they do at their company despite the
fact that he's doing it very quickly well we don't
really know what's going on here but you just
made things go 300 faster you're almost like a
computer you're like a machine i think one of the
reasons why vision doesn't know what's going on he
doesn't realize that this is a fake reality yet
like he knows who he is he knows he's an avenger
he knows about his powers but it seems like he's
missing some really critical information about
this fictional reality because it's scarlet witch
bringing him back to life inside this reality we
meet his boss mr heart which i think is kind of
a reference to vision in scarlet witch's heart
like this is all about scarlet wishes perspective
the show Wandavision the whole title of the show
Wandavision is literally a reference to wanda's
vision because it's her experiencing all this
it's from her perspective but the title is also
a reference to scarlet witch and vision together
like wanda and vision but also the nature of
their tv based reality Wandavision like you're
watching Wandavision so you start to see some of
the legion aspects of it if you never watched the
legion tv show on fx that was an x-men based tv
show but they got really trippy with perspective
you weren't quite sure what was real and what was
fake at various times and the legion character had
some powers that were similar to scarlet witch's
reality warping powers that she seems like she has
inside this reality being able to change anything
about the reality around him as he saw fit they
have all those funny moments about scarlet
witch trying to seduce vision because this
is supposed to be their night to get it on the
way they progress through the episode with their
relationship status the fact that they're slowly
trying to have children through the episodes the
children get older it's all meant to be very
serialized but the way they're playing it in
this episode is like it's happening for the very
first time then they have that first really funny
commercial but there's some really funny stuff
going on in this in the background if you notice
it's meant to be very meta and kind of commentary
about the nature of this fake reality so obviously
it's meant to be a big iron man easter egg because
the toastmate 2000 is made by stark industries so
the toaster itself has that red blinking light
on it the warning light that seems like it turns
into an alarm and the woman in the advertisement
starts to freak out a little bit when it goes off
the toaster itself is a reference to vision
himself because vision is property of stark
industries he was created from jarvis which was
created by tony stark he owns the jarvis code and
he was created from ultron who was also created
from stark industries parts so if you really want
to get technical iron man also owned ultron an
ultron created vision with part of jarvis in him
so technically iron man owns vision even though he
probably doesn't see it that way probably sees him
more as like this lost child then vision arrives
with the boss and they have that funny moment with
scarlet witch and her negligee just surprising him
like wait a minute what's going on here we have to
throw a dinner party they make a couple sokovia
references her being european then they make some
cold war russia jokes to the soviets because this
is 1950's cold war era some of the references that
agnes makes are avengers infinity war in avengers
endgame references she talks about cooking dinner
it'll be a snap referencing the snap from avengers
infinity war thanos snapping the infinity gauntlet
the hulk and then iron man snapping their
infinity gauntlets but the look on her face
when she says snap also makes it sound like she
knows about scarlet witch's powers to literally
snap her fingers and create things
around her and change them at will
so i think it's just another clever reference
to her showing her hand revealing that she knows
what's going on with this fake reality which i
think is another act of the harkness reference
they have a bunch of jokes about scarlet witch
cooking the chicken too much with her powers
burning it and then devolving it into eggs showing
you just how powerful she is in this reality and
then just throwing everything all over the place
with her telekinesis they also pay off the lobster
joke at the end of the episode too when it winds
up on the front of their door there's the very
obvious house of m wine bottle easter egg that
we've been talking about for a couple of months
maison du ma pre in french means house of
contempt but it's also house of m from the
comics very important scarlet witch storyline
where she creates a fictional reality for herself
because the Wandavision show is basically like
the mcu's version of house of m where at the end
of that she says no more mutants and gets rid of
98 of all mutants around the world but i think a
lot of us are expecting a reverse version of that
during this series where she creates a lot of mcu
mutants or at least makes it possible for them to
exist in the main mcu reality in marvel phase four
then mrs hart sort of sets things off asking
all the wrong questions and you get that really
dark scene it actually goes super dark and
turns into more of a twilight zone type of scene
where did you come from when did you get
married why don't you have any children
she also tells her husband mr heart to just chill
out let them wait they're setting up their story
which is also reference to scarlet witch literally
setting up their story because they don't really
have a story they were only together very briefly
before vision was killed so she has to come up
with their backstory on the fly so they can fit
into this fictional reality like she says later
in episodes this is meant to be our home i want us
to fit in when he starts banging on the table and
choking and they sort of zoom in with the camera
it also seems kind of like an alfred hitchcock
film almost like it's going into a horror scene
this is also one of the times you see her break
this reality on purpose for the first time when
she tells vision vision help him and use your
powers basically there's a little more of this
that happens in episode 2 that i'll talk about
in my episode 2 video but then they decide to
make tonight their anniversary they make rings
for each other announced that they're married
congratulations we're married then vision uses the
remote control to literally turn off the episode
like it sort of fades out after he hits the button
the funny thing about this too is that they made a
bunch of press kits for this and in it they had a
tv guide cover with them on it and all the buttons
on the remote control are made to be infinity
stones the mine stone there are also a lot of
mine stone references later in the episodes too
when you zoom out and transition to real life in
the control room it looks like a tv control room
of banks watching this fake reality watching
it like it's a show happening that you could
actually watch on tv i think because this pad
in front of here that the person is riding on
implies that this is the sword agents watching
her inside this reality just monitoring what's
actually going on as if it's a live tv feed it's a
little hard to tell but i feel like this is going
to be a big easter egg this person here i think
this is going to be the darcy character from the
thor movies played by kat dennings because
she's an important character but she was
barely in any of the trailers it would actually
be pretty funny that they made her be the one
to actually watch this all playing out and just
monitor scarlet witch just to see what's happening
minute to minute i also think that katherine hans
character is a big part of making what's happening
here actually go on because she seems like she
knows so much about what's happening inside
this alternate reality think about it this way
the way that she's in the credits catherine han
is the next most important character on the show
after vision in scarlet witch why would she be so
important to all the episodes of the series if
she weren't part of helping make this fictional
reality work then we had to talk a little bit
about the ending credits too they feel like
more traditional tv show credits that you would
expect from a modern show because they're doing
the old-timey stuff at the beginnings of all the
episodes the credits fade into the tv pixels red
blue green like a traditional tv almost like
it's a whole alternate reality building itself
out like you see all the different aspects of
it as if it's inside a computer but it's really
inside a tv screen you see vision being built
you see their home being built and it flies apart
it breaks apart everything spins up into their
rings then all the while this is happening it
starts glitching out just a little bit like you've
seen during all the trailers just referencing the
reality starting to crack the seams starting
to show just like in the house of m comics
but again this first episode which is meant to
reference the fictional reality you're not meant
to completely break it till a little bit later we
don't start to see the sword references to episode
2 so what will happen is i'll post my episode 2
video later tonight it's actually pretty short
episode there were actually a few reasons why
the first couple of episodes were so short mostly
because sitcoms of that era were about this length
they were very very short but also they want to
blow through the timeline through the black and
white episodes as quickly as possible just because
it's super weird and they don't want people to
think the entire show is going to be like this
i did see a lot of people in my timeline kind of
confused about what was going on don't worry it
will become more clear as more things around them
start to break the reality in the sword agents
start to break in more and more but if you spotted
any really big avengers or marvel easter eggs
in the episode that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
my episode 2 video should be up in a couple hours
as well what'll happen is i'll update the link at
the end of this video to my Wandavision episode 2
video but until then this will point to my marvel
captain america returns video and you can also
click here for that brand new black panther 2
teaser thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!